foreign
of cold fusion
preventing a war is difficult
hot tempers can get in the way of cool
and rational reasoning and the result of
war is something that nobody wants to
live through
War takes discussion and diplomacy
reason and thought
but what if a war could be stopped by
just one man
a man who chose to trust his gut instead
of a machine and not just any War but a
nuclear war between the United States
and Russia
in other words this one man
single-handedly stopped what would have
been World War III
sounds like something out of a science
fiction movie but one day back in 1983
this exact event happened
stanislav if graphovich Petrov a Russian
Lieutenant literally saved the world
without him it's possible that you
wouldn't be here and the World As We
Knew It Could Have Ended on that day so
what happened on that fateful day and
what would have happened if the two
superpowers nuked each other
well get comfortable and get ready for
an insane story this episode truly was
one of my favorites to make
[Music]
it's the 26th of September 1983 and 44
year old Russian military Lieutenant
stanislav Petrov sits at his console
it's been a regular day so far but
suddenly his screen lights up
it's five American nuclear missiles
coming straight towards Russia
he had a choice to make should he pick
up the phone and advise a retaliation
strike against the United States he
doesn't have much time to make a
decision if he acts America would be
nuked and a World War would erupt if he
does nothing he risks losing his fellow
countrymen's lives in a U.S nuclear
attack
at this point the weight of the world is
on his shoulders
but we need to rewind here how did the
world get to the point of one person
standing between normality and complete
annihilation
shortly after the end of the second
world war in 1945 hostilities started
Brewing between the United States and
the Soviet Union and from 1947 onwards
the world got divided into two
geopolitical blocks of power the Eastern
Bloc led by the Soviet Union and the
Western Bloc led by the United States
what ensued for the next couple of
decades is what we call the Cold War
though this period never had an actual
war between the two countries it was
characterized by a highly intense
Conflict for global domination which
involved Espionage and Military conflict
in foreign countries through proxy wars
the Korean Wars and Vietnam wars were
two such conflicts
the two Global Rivals competed with each
other to become the leader in various
aspects of science technology and
warfare through space exploration
nuclear development and an arms race
while the United States had an edge in
building nuclear weapons after the
ending of World War II the Soviets soon
caught up
by the 1960s the two were so much on par
with each other in regards to their
nuclear capabilities that they were
capable of destroying each other in a
nuclear war
this led to the concept of mutual
assured destruction which implied that
each one's offensive Weaponry surpassed
the defensive capability of the other
to drive this home in 1961 Russia tested
the Tsar bomber it was a hydrogen bomb
that was the most powerful weapon ever
created it was the equivalent of 54
megatons of TNT or to put it another way
all the explosive power of all the bombs
used in World War II at the same time
times 10.
when the Russian Tsar Bomba was dropped
the flash of the blast could be seen one
thousand kilometers away or 630 miles
and the mushroom cloud was 64 kilometers
high or 40 miles high
villagers 55 kilometers away were
flattened and damage was sustained by
buildings hundreds of miles away
radio communication was disrupted for
over an hour because of the radiation
the pilots who had dropped the bomb
almost lost control of their tu-95
bomber from the Shockwave blast and this
was despite being 50 kilometers or 30
miles away and placing a parachute on
the bomb so it could slowly float down
to earth while they had a chance to
escape
third degree burns were possible from
hundreds of kilometers away and shock
waves from the blast were still being
recorded on its third revolution around
the Earth
it's insane to think that in the
original Soviet designs the Tsar Bomba
was supposed to be twice as powerful
needless to say the possibility of
nuclear war was always a dark dread a
dread that loomed overhead the citizens
of planet Earth throughout the 60s 70s
and 80s
foreign
it was September of 1983.
tensions were running High between the
East and the West the United States was
busy developing psychological warfare
exercises against Moscow and the Soviet
Union was expecting that the US was
going to launch an attack and there was
a reason for this
the Soviets had just shot down a Korean
Airlines commercial flight that crossed
into Soviet airspace killing a
congressman from Georgia among 269
passengers
anxiety had started to mount when the
flight from New York to Seoul with a
stop in Anchorage wasn't heard from for
several hours then came the unavoidable
Savage truth it had disappeared from the
sky Itself by heat-seeking missile fired
by a Soviet su-15 Interceptor among
those presumed dead United States
senator Larry McDonald and at least 30
possibly 40 other Americans and an
Australian family of four in Washington
Secretary of State Schultz said this was
no accident President Reagan at his
Californian Ranch was said to have been
briefed continually birds can scarcely
express our revulsion at this horrifying
act of violence that flight 7 was
substantially off course and well into
Soviet airspace over some of the most
sensitive and jealously guarded airspace
the Soviets have
because underneath is a nuclear
submarine base and air fighter base and
the missile testing range from Moscow
the silence was deafening
on the early morning of the 26th of
September 1983
weeks after the downed Korean flight the
world came the closest it's ever been to
ending
Lieutenant stanislav Petrov sat down at
his computer and began his shift at
serpicov 15. a command center stationed
just outside of Moscow
he had been on his shift for a few hours
when suddenly the ballistic missile
early warning system began to sound
[Music]
Soviets early warning satellites over
the United States had detected an
intercontinental ballistic missile being
fired from a U.S base
shocked Petrov began to try and wrap his
head around the situation of what had
just happened
suddenly the system set off four more
alarms one after the other implying that
the United States had launched a total
of five intercontinental ballistic
missiles
the warning system had changed its alert
from launch to missile strike and it
showed that the reliability of These
Warnings was at the highest level
Petrov was now truly shocked
Petrov was a critical Link in the chain
of decision making on retaliation in the
case of a missile strike by the U.S he
had studied radio engineering at a
Soviet Air Force Base in Kiev and joined
the Soviet Air Defense Forces and Rose
through the ranks over the years
his role now was to oversee the staff
that monitored signals from the early
warning satellites
there were no specific rules for
deciding if a warning was a false alarm
or not it was totally dependent on
Petrov and whether he decided to report
to his seniors the circumstances
demanded that any early warning of a
missile strike being reported promptly
so that those at the highest level of
command could make a decision quickly
as Juniors at the station waited for
Petrov to make a decision he sat Frozen
in his chair and couldn't bring himself
to quickly dial and Report
once reported to his superiors it would
all be out of his hands and probably
result in a nuclear strike against the
United States
but doing nothing would risk his entire
nation
take a second and think to yourself what
would you do
holding a phone in one hand and an
intercom in the other Petrov pondered
over the consequences that his decision
would lead to
after five minutes he decided that the
warnings from the system were false
alarms and reported the same to his
superiors at the headquarters
they trusted his decision and didn't
order a missile strike on the US
foreign
but now Petrov had to wait had he made
the right decision did his failure to
act cause the death of Millions
Lieutenant Petrov stressed in a sea of
his own thoughts this went on for
roughly 25 minutes
he then realized that if there was an
actual attack he would have come to know
within that time
the more time that passed the more
relaxed he became
finally he concluded he had indeed made
the right decision
so how could this have happened
the false alarm was set off by primitive
80s technology
the Soviet Satellites that were
monitoring the incoming missiles
mistakenly identified the sun's
reflection off the top of clouds for a
missile launch the coding in the program
was supposed to filter out such wrong
stimuli the coders didn't do a good
enough job
the code was later Rewritten to avoid
such dangerous incidents in the future
in interviews given during his later
years Lieutenant Petrov revealed that
the early warning system of the Soviets
had been introduced in haste as the
United States had launched a similar
system and because of this he didn't
consider the system 100 reliable and
believed that humans being the creator
of such computer systems were wiser than
them
the critical decision was taken based
purely on a guess quote I had a funny
feeling in my gut he told the Washington
Post
he explained that it originated from his
skepticism of the early warning system
and the realization that if the US
wasn't deed going to attack it wouldn't
just fire five missiles
so what would have happened if the US
did retaliate
if Petrov had chosen to interpret the
warnings as a real attack in 1983 the
Soviets may have launched a fierce
attack on the United States leading to a
retaliation from the U.S ending in
mutual Annihilation for both Nations
a 1979 study by the U.S office of
Technology assessment States the
following a nuclear war between the U.S
and Soviet Union would cause around 35
to 77 of the population of the United
States to have been wiped out
and the Soviets would have lost 20 to 40
percent of its population any war
between the two nations would have
inevitably led to their allies getting
involved leading to a third world war
so what would a nuclear bomb do to a
city
a 10 kiloton bomb detonated on the
ground of Times Square in New York would
explode with a flash so bright that it
would briefly blind people for hundreds
of miles a massive Fireball with core
temperatures running at millions of
degrees would immediately erupt
everyone and everything within 100 feet
of the blast would be completely
annihilated
a one mile radius would be charred and a
500 mile an hour pressure wave would
expand out destroying everything in its
path
and all of this would happen within a
few seconds of the blast
radioactive particle dust would be
spread and scattered all over the city
people exposed to this dust would suffer
from acute radiation syndrome showing
early symptoms such as dizziness nausea
headaches and vomiting within a matter
of hours this would be followed by
symptoms such as fever seizures diarrhea
hair loss and bleeding in the mouth and
under the skin
victims may also experience more severe
symptoms over the next couple of weeks
and most of these people would
eventually die
an electromagnetic pulse generated along
with the blast would disable electronic
devices such as computers cell phones
and communication Towers up to several
miles away
if more attacks are carried out the
sheer amount of smoke would block
sunlight and plunge the global
temperature by several degrees for years
leading to a phenomenon called nuclear
winter this may affect crops and lead to
a famine
so I think we can all agree we have to
say thanks to Petrov for helping us all
avoid such an outcome
after the nuclear missile incident was
avoided at first Petrov was initially
praised for his calm while facing an
unprecedented and critical situation
soon after this he was investigated over
the incident among the questions he was
asked during his interrogation was why
had he failed to record everything in
his logbook to this he famously replied
that he had a phone in one hand and an
intercom in the other and didn't have a
third hand he was let go with a
reprimand
according to Petrov it was just a matter
of Pride because he had found multiple
bugs in the early warning systems and
because of this it would become
unfavorable for his employers to reward
him it may also be why his story isn't
widely known
Petrov was long forgotten after the
incident and was reduced to growing
potatoes for a living
in fact almost nobody on Earth knew
about their almost destruction until
1998 when a retired commander of Soviet
missile defense Yuri V votinstev had his
Memoir published in the Memoir he told
this story and that was the first time
that this became public
and from this point the world finally
recognized what Petrov had done and
lauded him for his role in averting the
Third World War
in 2006 he received an award from the
association of world citizens in the
United States
in 2013 he was honored with the dress
and Peace Prize and in 2014 a Danish
documentary called the man who saved the
world was made about him
Petrov died at the age of 77 on May 19
2017 in a Moscow suburb where he lived
alone on a small pension
it is a very humble end to a man who was
so pivotal to world history again
without him we might not be here
and I just find this story fascinating
the story of how one person changed the
course of history and potentially saved
Millions upon millions of lives by
essentially deciding to do nothing
but let's take this opportunity to
collectively remind ourselves that
Nations going to war in this fashion is
something that nobody wants
thanks so much for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the episode
I may already be at 3 million
subscribers by the time this goes out so
a huge thank you to all of you who
decided that you liked my videos enough
to subscribe I'm thinking of doing a
live chat over at the cold fusion
Discord to celebrate I'm sure I have
more details on that later
I also wanted to do a quick correction
on the last video I said that a
neighborhood was bought by an investment
firm but I didn't make the distinction
that that neighborhood wasn't open for
buying to the public and was intended
only for wholesale it was pointed out by
some of you so I thought I'd clear that
up
anyway my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next episode cheers
guys
have a good one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]